CHAMBER WITH OVERPAID SPOILED
BRAT ANCHORS THAT DO NOT DO
THEIR JOB.
AND JOINING US IS JOE.
AND HE AND HIS WIFE VICTORIA
CAME TO A CHRISTMAS PARTY AND
SHARED A DRINK TOGETHER AND
TALKED AND LAUGH.
SO MUCH NEWS WAS MADE IN THE
INTERVIEW.
>> INDEED.
>> Sean: YOU SAW THE COVERAGE.
YOUR REACTION, WHAT DOES IT SAY
TO THE AMERICAN CONSUMER ABOUT
THE NEWS SFRAE IN GENERAL IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS DINNER AND
THE CONDUCT OF THE PEOPLE AND
LOOK AT THE ABSENCE OF COVERAGE
AS YOUR SHOW LAST NIGHT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT AMERICAN
JOURNALISM IS DEAD, DYING AND IN
THE COFFIN.
THEY ARE NOT JOURNALIST.
THEY ARE PEOPLE WITH AN AGENDA
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO FIND
SOMETHING OUT.
THEY WANT TO SAY SOMETHING ON
THEIR OWN.
IT IS AN EXAMPLE AND IT IS
A SAD, SAD DAY.
>> Sean: JOE, WE HAVE HAD
MASKING SURVEILLANCE ABUSE AND
LEAKING OF RAW INTELLIGENCE AND
SAMANTHA POWER, AND THEN THE
BIGGER SCANDAL.
RUDY GUILIANI IS RIGHT.
HILLARY COMMITTED FELONIES AND
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICES.
JAMES COMEY AND LORETTA LYNCH
RIGGED THE INVESTIGATION.
AND TURNS OUT HILLARY IS PAYING
A FOREIGN NATIONAL TO USE
RUSSIAN SOURCES THAT TURN OUT TO
BE DEBUNKED AND THAT FALSE
POLITICAL DOCUMENT AND DESZIER
IS USED FOR A FISA WARPT TO SPY
ON AN AMERICAN IN A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE SILENT ON THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER AND SCANDAL IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
JUDGMENT IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
IT IS QUITE EVIDENT THAT THE
MUELLER PROBE IS ILLEGITIMATE.
AND THE ATTEMPT TO INTERVIEW OF
THE PRESIDENT UNITED STATES.
THERE IS NO DOUBT AT ALL THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE REFUSE TO BE
INTERVIEWED BY THEM.
IT IS CLEAR THAT ARE MUELLER AND
THE DEMOCRATIC THUG ARE ACT
NOTHING BAD FAITH.
THEY KNOW THE PRESIDENT UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF RULES CAN'T BE
INDICTED.
AND THEY HAVE NO EVIDENCE TO
INDICT HIM.
THE OFFICE OF MUELLER WAS
CREATED BY ROB ROSENSTEIN
ILLEGALLY.
AND ALL OF THIS LEADS TO THE
ULTIMATE CONCLUSION THAT THE
PERPETUTION OF THE INVESTIGATION
BY MULLER IS DOING GRAVE DAMAGE
TO THE UNITED STATES AND FOREIGN
POLICY AND GRAVE DAMAGE TO U.S.
LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF THE
THUG- LIKE TACTICS USED IN THE
MANAFORT CASE.
AND AFTER WATCHING THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES, ROD ROSENSTEIN ACCUSE
CONGRESS OF TRYING TO EXTORT HIM
AND OTHERS IN THE DEPARTMENT BY
CONDUCTING LEGITIMATE
CONSTITUTIONAL OVERSIGHT.
I WOULD SAY BETWEEN MUELLER AND
ROSENSTEIN, AND THE ABSENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL, GOD BLESS HIM,
WE HAVE A SERIOUS CRISIS IN
AMERICAN FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Sean: I AGREE.
I THINK IT IS IT A BIGGEST
ABUSE.
AND HE WOULD BE A WITNESS ON
THAT PART.
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN, WE TALKED
ABOUT THE FISAN APPLICATIONS
THAT RELIED ON UNVERIFIED AND
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY
CLINTON.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE IT WAS
PAID FOR BY HILLARY.
AND IF THERE ARE FALSE
INFORMATION PRESENTED TO A FISA
COURT, HE IS IMPLICATING HIMSELF
WHEN HE SAID HE WOULD NOT BE
EXTORTED.
>> OF COURSE, THE PROBLEM FOR
ROB ROSENSTEIN AND HE HAS